galaxien entstehen wahrscheinlich
vollkommen anders als bisher gedacht
forscher haben jetzt schwarze löcher
beobachtet in deren nähe etwas geschieht
mit dem so niemand gerechnet hat in
ihrer umgebung entstehen sterne
obwohl das bisher für ausgeschlossen
gehalten wurde denn eigentlich machen
schwarze löcher genau das gegenteil sie
verschlingen materie
warum jetzt genau das gegenteil entdeckt
wurde und warum es unser weltbild auf
den kopf stellt das jetzt in kriegs und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
was schwarze löcher machen ist
eigentlich klar ihre gravitation ist so
stark dass selbst licht ihnen nicht
entkommen kann alles in ihrer nähe
verschlingen sie und so wächst ihre
masse immer mehr an in ihrem zentrum ist
alles auf einen punkt zusammen gestürzt
die singularität so vermutet man
trotzdem scheinen sie eine größe zu
haben ihr ereignishorizont ist nämlich
die grenze hinter der ihnen nichts mehr
entweichen kann von außen wird er wie
eine hülle wahrgenommen wobei das auch
eigentlich ist denn hinter ihm beginnt
eben die region aus der nicht entweichen
kann außerhalb der eigenen sorgen sonst
ist das aber noch möglich und genau das
ist das verrückte die starke gravitation
bewirkt auch dramatische ereignisse
außerhalb des schwarzen lochs bzw
korrekt ausgedrückt außerhalb des
ereignishorizont das beginnt schon mit
der akkretionsscheibe die inzwischen
weitestgehend bekannt ist um das
schwarze loch bildet sich eine scheibe
mit materie die sehr schnell um das
schwarze loch kreis diese hohe
geschwindigkeit muss sie haben um durch
die zentrifugalkraft also die kraft nach
außen der gravitation des schwarzen
loches entgegenzuwirken durch die hohe
geschwindigkeit wird diese scheibe sehr
heiß und bringt so das schwarze loch
sogar zum leuchten also natürlich nicht
das schwarze loch selbst sondern eben
diese scheibe aber dadurch kann es
beobachtet werden und jetzt sind
forscher um robert ohmayer lino von der
university cambridge einem weiteren
phänomen auf die spur gekommen schon
eine weile gab es die hypothese dass
schwarze löcher zwar auch einen strom
hoch energetischer teilchen quasi in
alle winde zerstreuen aber dass diese
materie winde eben auch zur entstehung
von sternen führen nämlich dann wenn sie
die materie winde in interstellare
materie wolken blasen und sieht damit
zusammendrücken aber es war eben nur
eine hypothese jetzt haben die forscher
mit dem very large telescope am paranal
observatorium der europäischen
südsternwarte in chile zwei
kollidierende galaxien beobachtet
katalognummer sf 23 128 - 59 19
und dabei konnten sie das hypothetische
phänomen direkt beobachten vom zentralen
schwarzen loch im zentrum einer der
galaxien ging ein materie wind aus
in ihm bildeten sich sterne um
nachzuweisen dass es junge sterne waren
untersuchten sie die sterne noch mit
zwei der leistungsfähigsten
spektrografen junge sterne bringen
nämlich die gaswolken um sie herum auf
eine bestimmte art zum leuchten und
genau das taten sie check und sie flogen
mit hoher geschwindigkeit vom zentrum
der galaxie weg und noch etwas absolut
verblüffendes so entstehen dort in den
materien sterne mit einer masse von 30
sonnenmassen pro jahr das ist ein
viertel aller sterne die dort entstehen
und diese menge verändert unser weltbild
also jedenfalls das von astrophysikern
demnach könnten nämlich galaxien ganz
anders als bisher gedacht entstehen
diese entdeckung könnte auch die
unterschiedlichen formen von galaxien
erklären welche wie unsere milchstraße
spiralförmig mit einem diffusen
sternenhaufen in der mitte oder
elliptische galaxien mit einer struktur
losen sternen wallung dass ein so großer
anteil von sternen in den materie winden
der schwarzen löcher in diesem fall
entsteht könnte diese unterschiede
erklären und noch etwas könnte durch sie
besser erklärt werden die kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung sterne aus diesem
materie winde könnten in den
interstellaren raum schießen und dort
als supernova explodieren die überreste
dieser kosmischen ereignissen würden wir
dann in der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung sie hätte wäre wenn
noch ist vieles unklar und es ist noch
viel forschung nötig um das alles zu
erklären das neueste dazu erfahrt ihr
wie immer hier bei pixum 21 entwischen
täglich einfach mir hier ein abo aufs
auge drücken und nicht vergessen er
einen auf die glocken zu geben und wir
noch nicht abonniert hat das hier habt
ihr auf jeden fall verpasst unsere
besser playlist viel spaß dabei bis dann
bleibt dran